So far all of the procedures you've written have been quite simple,
only needed a line or maybe two of code to finish them.
Now we're going to try a quiz which is going to be much more challenging,
and I'm going to give it a gold star to show that this is an especially challenging quiz.
If you can get this one on your own, you're really understanding things very well.
If you get stuck on this one, that's okay.
They'll be some hints to make it a little easier, and then hopefully you'll understand
the answer after you see it, and you'll have a lot more chances especially on the homework
to try some harder questions on your own.
So here's the question.
Your goal is to define a procedure, and we'll call this one find_second.
It takes 2 strings as its inputs, so the first input is the search string.
The second input is the target string.
And your goal is to print out the position of the second occurrence of the target string
in the search string.
It should output a number that is the position of the second occurrence of the target string
I'll show you an example in the Python interpreter of what find_second should do,
then you should try and solve this on your own.
For an example, here's the quote we had in unit 1 from George Danton,
and if we evaluate find_second, passing in danton as the first input
and 'audace' as the second,
what we should get is the position of the second occurrence of 'audace'
in the input string danton.
When we run this, we see that we get 25, which is that position.